buongiorno a tutti non è proprio della
tecnologia dei materiali nanostrutturati
fa poca differenza per quello che
discutiamo discutiamo oggi e sono molto
contento di essere qui perché è
l'argomento che cerchiamo di toccare è
un argomento
diciamo che di per sé mette i brividi
non siamo il punto nasce da questa
osservazione cioè è tempo di provare
seriamente a capire come funziona il
cervello e questa consapevolezza diciamo
dell'opportunità che ci si presenta
nasce dal fatto che nella comunità
internazionale in tutto il mondo è ormai
giunta la come dire la convergenza
sull'idea che le conoscenze che ci sono
state sviluppate e le tecnologie da una
parte che sono disponibili possono
aprire delle opportunità nuove per
provare a capire qualcosa in più del
cervello qui è riportata una un
riferimento di un iniziativa americana
ma ce ne sono anche in tutto il mondo
anche in europa
ne parleranno i colleghi con cui stavamo
di chiudendo dietro le quinte
anche in europa e però è una cosa
importante interessante capire vorrei
riportare quello che il presidente stati
uniti ha citato nel lanciare questa
iniziativa dicendo noi come esseri umani
siamo capaci di esplorare delle galassie
che sono lontane anni luce ma di fatto
non conosciamo praticamente nulla della
materia biologica che abbiamo tra le
nostre orecchie e questo è un dato se ci
pensate è veramente come dire striking
non è un dato è un dato che ci colpisce
a me colpisce moltissimo questo questo
aspetto per cui partiamo partiamo da lì
ovviamente parlando di queste tematiche
dobbiamo assolutamente essere coscienti
del fatto che bisogna approcciare questi
temi in maniera molto delicata molto con
estrema cautela e con estremo rigore
sono temi che hanno un impatto dal punto
di vista etico morale sociale ed
economico estremamente grande ed è
questo è particolarmente vero come
quando persone come noi vorrebbero
provare ad esplorare addirittura un chip
che possa essere messo in intimo
contatto con i neuroni e quindi con il
cervello
questo è il come dire un obiettivo che
pone tante domande ma che probabilmente
l'unico modo per riuscire effettivamente
a trovare una via di lettura di un
sistema così complesso come quello del
del cervello e di che cosa mi presento
qua come come dire io appartengo come ha
detto giustamente andrea
nell'introduzione al consiglio nazionale
delle ricerche lo facciamo ovviamente a
livello istituzionale cercando di dare
corpo alla missione della nostra
istituzione che è quella di generare
conoscenza di creare avanzamenti di
conoscenza attraverso la ricerca per
contribuire allo sviluppo sia sociale
che economico e tecnologico del paese
ecco siccome abbiamo tutti siamo qua
perché cerchiamo di sognare non si
chiama di avere una visione di lungo
termine e una visione estremamente come
dire di prospettiva
proprio a me un po cambiate un po di
indulgenza su questo piace anche essere
molto concreto e cioè la visione alla
missione estremamente estremamente bella
estremamente come dire challenging per
usare una parola molto di moda però poi
noi che cosa siamo in grado di fare e
come come ci ci caliamo in una realtà
quale può essere il nostro contributo
vero reale all'interno di questo tipo di
iniziative e qui vi faccio vedere
un'immagine anche non solo quanti di voi
sono bolognesi comunque questo è il figo
una figura una fotografia dell'area
della ricerca che si trova a pochi passi
da qui in via gobetti
questo perché lo faccio vedere lo faccio
vedere perchè sarai sicuramente
importante questo vorrei che fosse un
messaggio che alla fine ci portiamo via
un po tutti cioè è sicuramente
importante per promuovere l'innovazione
avere delle idee brillanti avere delle
intuizioni ma poi queste vanno vanno
certificate vanno vanno portate avanti e
vanno verificate con tutti i canoni
tipici di un di un atteggiamento
rigoroso dal punto di vista scientifico
e tecnologico quindi le infrastrutture
un'infrastruttura come questa è
è una conditio sine qua non per poter
verificare appunto delle consolidare
delle vere livelli avanzamenti di
conoscenza questa è una realtà che porta
insieme varie varie componenti come
potete vedere una componente istituti di
ricerca ma ci sono anche start up nate
da risultati della ricerca e mischia
varie componenti porta insieme persone
che si occupano di cose veramente molto
diverse una dall'altra
ed è un pre requisito per poter provare
ad affrontare problemi come quello dello
studio del cervello che richiede
assolutamente di superare le barriere di
diciamo delle conoscenze il pro di cui
parliamo è questo questa è un'immagine
che rappresenta un neurone quindi il
blog diciamo l'immagine blu con le sue
con i suoi assoni con le sue diramazioni
che viene messo in intimo contatto con
un chip elettronico
questo è un approccio che non è nuovo
nel senso che si è tentato da vari da
vario tempo di mettere in collegamento
il le reti neuronali il cervello con
elettronica il il punto fondamentale che
l'elettronica di cui parliamo
elettronica che noi abbiamo i nostri
telefonini che abbiamo che è pervasiva
nel nostro mondo cioè elettronica al
silicio che alcune caratteristiche
estremamente interessanti dal punto
vista delle prestazioni ma è come dire
l'antipodo di ciò che serve per andare
ad interferire ad interagire in maniera
rispettosa in maniera in maniera non
invasiva con la materia biologiche con
il cervello in particolare quindi questo
ci porta ad avere una serie di
limitazioni nell'utilizzo di questo
approccio per quel che riguarda la
biocompatibilità cioè noi non possiamo
alterare da da nessun punto di vista le
caratteristiche funzionali e
morfologiche di un cervello di una rete
neuronale altrimenti ne perdiamo le sue
caratteristiche è ovviamente il fatto
che questi due mondi siano distinti e
distanti dal punto di vista di affinità
chimica e biochimica fa sì che
l'interazione non sia assolutamente
quella ideale cioè questi due mondi
tendono cieli forziamo a stare insieme
ma non ci vorrebbero stare
per essere molto molto poi semplici su
questo ecco nel momento in cui noi
cerchiamo di avere un chip che possa
dialogare efficacemente con i neuroni
sicuramente abbiamo alcuni requisiti che
dobbiamo tenere a mente il primo
requisito è che dobbiamo rispettare la
sinuosità e la struttura estremamente
complessa e la morfologia estremamente
complessa e frastagliata del cervello
quindi siamo alla ricerca di una
tecnologia che potenzialmente è
flessibile qui non un pezzo di diciamo
di silicio che è rigido per definizione
ma che sia una tecnologia flessibile una
tecnologia che sia poco invasiva soffice
e rispettosa delle caratteristiche
fisiologiche del cervello
l'altro elemento vogliamo che sia
potenzialmente molto biocompatibile cioè
che il cervello e le reti neuronali la
vedono come una tecnologia non è
estranea non esterno non da combattere
un po per evitare quel fenomeno che si
ha quando mettiamo le protesi di
prevenire infezioni e rigetto altro
elemento importante siccome il cervello
noi non lo conosciamo
sarebbe ideale poter avere delle porte
di comunicazione tra i nostri chip e il
cervello con uno spettro ampio di
possibilità di comunicazione e quindi
avere dei materiali che possono
esprimere varie funzioni in particolare
elettrica e diciamo con possibilità di
generazione di impulsi di luce ci dà uno
spettro in partenza molto più elevato è
ampio delle possibilità poi di andare
effettivamente a portare un interazione
tra il mondo dell'elettronica e il mondo
delle reti neuronali
ecco il queste alcune di queste
caratteristiche vi faccio vedere questa
questa slide queste a questa immagine
with e non c'entrano assolutamente nulla
ed è vero non c'entra assolutamente
nulla però questa è un settore di
attività di anche industriali che sta
che è molto che emergente che sta
emergendo in maniera molto prepotente in
cui ritroviamo alcune delle
caratteristiche che abbiamo identificato
come necessarie per poter immaginare di
avere una piattaforma tecnologica che
possa interagire con il neurone con le
reti neuronali
questa è una cosa di cui pian piano
cominciamo a sentire cioè significa fare
elettronica con materiali flessibili con
materiali plastici e sta per entrare
nella nostra vita attraverso alcune in
the application e molto molto comune
molto diffuse la prima è che ci
sostituiranno il concetto di lampadina e
il concetto di bulbo per illuminare una
stadio qua vedo una serie di lampadine
messe il tutto intorno al teatro questo
concetto sparirà sparirà perché dove
verranno viceversa integrate all'interno
dei vari elementi architettonici dei
fogli illuminanti delle pellicole delle
superfici che possono seguire anche dal
punto di vista estetico e architettonico
molto meglio i profili un ambiente e
quindi e fare tutto questo per produrre
illuminazione con una maggiore
efficienza e con bassi consumi
energetici
l'altro elemento che sta per arrivare
avrete sentito con gli annunci anche
recenti di telefonini che cominciano a
essere curvino diciamo il telefonino che
non è più piatto rigido come stiamo
abbiamo oggi noi in tasca ma cominciano
essere televisori telefonini curvi
arrotondati perché perché sta
anticipando quello che arriverà un mondo
in cui l'elettronica sarà flessibile
un esempio per tutti la possibilità di
avere per esempio un televisore che sia
come una tenda che io ho rotto desoto
nel momento in cui mi serve e quello
sarà il modo in cui poi noi interagiremo
con questo tipo di interfaccia ora che
cosa c'entra questo con i neuroni ma
diciamo cosa c'entra il principio nulla
però se noi attraversiamo
se i confini dei settori tecnologici e
soprattutto abbiamo l'audace il coraggio
di attraversare i confini delle
discipline di conoscenza e disciplina e
tecnologiche scientifiche ci accorgiamo
che molte delle conoscenze che sono
sviluppate per quel tipo di applicazioni
per quel tipo di settore possono essere
utili per affrontare in maniera nuova un
problema come quello della interazione
con con i neuroni
ecco il punto di partenza e diciamo del
lavoro che poi vi presento perché è un
lavoro concretamente realizzato e
concretamente realizzato nei luoghi e
nelle strutture che vi ho
fatto vedere un attimo fa è quello di
conoscere in modo approfondito un
microchip organico un microchip organico
che ovviamente a tutta la struttura di
un di un dispositivo elettronico che può
essere fatto su substrati flessibili
trasparenti come vedete in queste
immagini il il punto fondamentale poi di
portare i neuroni in intimo contatto con
questi con questi chip e questo
ovviamente va fatto esponendo il chip
microchip organico in un ambiente
fisiologico che favorisca la crescita
favorisca la fisiologia delle reti
neuronale questo non è ad esempio questo
liquido fucsia che vedete è la soluzione
fisiologica che serve a far sì che il
neurone sia vitale e mantenga le sue
funzionalità
ecco il primo siccome noi stiamo
mettendo insieme due mondi da una parte
c'è il neurone che deve essere alla rete
neuronale che deve essere messe in
contatto con un chip elettronico quindi
ci dobbiamo assicurare che il neurone
sia ancora vivo e sia funzionale un
neurone funzionale quando tra virgolette
sparacio è a un'attività bioelettrica
che viene riconosciuta come un impulso
diciamo di corrente e questo è una cosa
che abbiamo verificato come vedete ci
sono spari del neurone misurati
direttamente in contatto sul sul
dispositivo
ovviamente queste condizioni sono anche
estremamente importanti e severe dal
punto di vista del dispositivo
elettronico quindi lui deve continuare a
lavorare nelle condizioni in cui che noi
dobbiamo imporre affinché il neurone
rimanga e rimanga vivo e questo è
dimostrato con queste con queste curve
il transistor dal componente elettronica
continua a funzionare propriamente ecco
però questo non è sufficiente non è non
è sufficiente che il neurone sia vivo e
mantenga la sua funzionalità fisiologica
e anche importante che le cellule
neuronali possano poi stare talmente
bene che possano proliferare che possono
mantenere le loro connessioni e
sviluppare un numero crescente di
cellule sul dispositivo e questo è
rappresentato in questa immagine in cui
vedete che ad un certo momento c'è un
neurone abbastanza isolato sul sud sul
chip dopo un po di tempo
uno dice neuronale aumenta significa che
i neuroni ci stanno proprio bene c'è
un'affinità dal punto di vista chimico e
biochimico estremamente estremamente
elevata ecco questo tutto questo
percorso che vi ho raccontato in poche
parole è un percorso che ovviamente
prima di essere reso pubblico è
ufficiale è stato sottoposto a dei
rigorosi controlli scientifici da parte
della comunità scientifica
internazionale che è durato circa due
anni cioè noi per due anni abbiamo
aperto le nostre ricerche abbiamo aperto
i nostri risultati erano stati valutati
e selezionati in tutti i modi possibili
e immaginabili
fino a quando abbiamo avuto come dire la
l'okay della comunità scientifica e in
questo modo il risultato poi è stato
portato come un avanzamento proposto
all'interno della comunità
internazionale e di fatto che cosa è
successo
abbiamo ottenuto una nuova piattaforma
tecnologica flessibile e trasparente che
si è in grado appunto di avere quel
requisito fondamentale necessario per
interagire con sistema come come il il
cervello abbiamo una migliore
biocompatibilità cioè questo oggetto può
rimanere a contatto con le reti
neuronali molto più a lungo di quanto
non si possa fare oggi con le tecnologie
elettroniche tradizionali e soprattutto
l'elemento più importante è che la
qualità del segnale che siano in grado
di leggere che siamo in grado di
ottenere da questa interazione è 16
volte migliore rispetto a quella di un
sistema commerciale tradizionale
ovviamente questo è il punto
fondamentale perché da qui si apre la
prospettiva di fare degli studi più
avanzati gli studi migliori per accedere
a dei domini che finora erano
assolutamente inaccessibili
con questo tipo di approcci e di
tecnologie quali sono i prossimi passi
per non smentire noi stessi il primo
passo da fare è quello di vedere se
questo approccio è valido anche per
altri tipi di cellule quindi lo andremo
a valutare gli interni di applicabilità
a cellule per esempio di tipo cardiaca
però l'elemento fondamentale sarà
sicuramente di passare da indagini
esclusivamente di laboratorio ad
indagini in vivo e quindi con su sistemi
in cui il
il cervello è mantenuto nelle sue
condizioni naturali ovviamente questo
poi apre la possibilità di strumenti di
tipo biomedici per la diagnosi e la cura
di martire normali e soprattutto volendo
lavorare ragionare in termini di
innovazione di lungo termine e può
essere un apporto importante per
comunicare in maniera direzionale con il
cervello cioè dare informazioni e
ricevere informazioni dal cervello in
avendo un contatto di tipo in intimo con
la materia cerebrale
chiudo velocemente per tornando al tema
di oggi non l'innovazione esponenziale
l'innovazione esponenziale da mio punto
di vista per la piccola esperienza che
ho per la realtà che che rappresento ha
bisogno sicuramente di ragionare oltre
gli schemi e ragionare oltre gli schemi
di ciò che oggi consolidato interni di
strutturazione delle conoscenze e di
delle discipline che sono diciamo ben
ben organizzate che hanno sicuramente un
utilità ma bisogna riuscire a combinare
a mischiare ea contaminare moltissimo
l'altra cosa è l'idea è importante ma le
infrastrutture in cui validare queste
idee per poterne considerare un vero
avanzamento di conoscenza è essenziale
senza un ambiente che favorisca questo è
che consolidi il tipo di conoscenze le
intuizioni che persone possono avere
noi andremo avanti in maniera caotica e
senza portare un vero avanzamento di
conoscenze l'altro elemento fondamentale
che è quello che abilita tutto questo è
quello che è assolutamente
irrinunciabile è il capitale umano
se vogliamo fare qualunque tipo di
innovazione in particolare quel
esponenziale investiamo sul capitale
umano grazie